hi there Steve Kaufman here I've decided
to turn over a new leaf we're nearing
the end of the year and I'm thinking
about what I have been doing and what I
should do and here's what's going to
change my videos are going to become
shorter two to three minutes long not
necessarily this one but starting with
the next videos probably coinciding with
the new year shorter and I'm going to
talk about language learning and I'm
going to talk also about the specific
problems of specific languages so some
advice on learning and more detailed
advice than I have given before on
learning French or Spanish or Chinese or
Japanese and so forth I'm also going to
do those in other languages and when I
do them in other languages I will
provide a translation and a you know
scratch transcript and therefore
captions so that's what's new I've been
kind of looking at at what I've been
doing I've been making videos since 2007
I'm gonna post a link if I remember to
some of those earlier videos that's a
long time I mean that's more than seven
years that I've been doing videos so
it's time to change um you know my whole
involvement with this language thing
came about because I basically because I
decided to learn Cantonese at age 55 and
so I was listed learning largely
listening to radio and came in contact
with his immigrant when we tried to help
and out of that develop the product or a
system called the linguist which was the
predecessor of link and and I always
thought that the word linguist meant
someone who speaks many languages which
is the first definition in any
dictionary of the english language even
though in other languages it doesn't
mean that it means someone who studies
linguistics which is also a meaning in
english but the meaning that most
english speakers are familiar with is
someone who speaks many languages and
that was the original meaning when the
further this word language was first
used back in the 16th century so i wrote
a book in fact called the linguist i
wrote it
in English in 2002 where I talked about
my own experiences in learning nine
languages and I couldn't find a copy of
the English version but I had this
chinese version kicking around and this
is one that was published in 2004 in
China I went to China on two occasions
to promote the book and of course at
that time I spoke nine languages most of
my career has been initially as a
diplomat seven years and then in the
forest industry so this whole
involvement with sort of the deliberate
learning of languages is something that
happened late in my toilet working
career but everything that I wrote in
here about language learning which was
based on my experience of learning
Mandarin Chinese and Japanese and
Spanish and German and so forth while
working while working with the exception
of the Chinese when I was a full-time
language student paid for by the
Canadian government for a year uh all
these experiences and what I learned and
what I shall work for me does
necessarily work for everyone he's in
the book and it hasn't changed very much
and so what I'm going to do next year
though I want to take some of my
experience and what I've learned since
because since 2004 since the book was
written I have learned three Slavic
languages Russian Czech and Ukrainian
and I have learned Portuguese which is
similar to spanish and some Romanian bit
rusty right now and some Korean so again
using the methods that are in the book
the methods that are essentially part of
of link I have learned these additional
six languages again the initial program
called the linguist basically only
offered English and we decided to make
that a multi-language platform we now
offer 21 languages at link so new format
shorter transcripts a lot of things that
I've been hearing from some of you I
must I enjoy doing these videos i enjoy
rambling on I enjoy getting reactions
from people I would like to have more
interaction with people and so I
would invite people who want to have a
conversation with me in their native
language which may not be English or who
want to talk about learning some
language where we could speak in both
English or and and or the language
they're learning please let me know I'd
be happy to also do some of those in the
new year but essentially it's a new year
okay and so new format and this isn't my
New Year's message is just to let you
know that things are gonna change and
even with that this video's a little
shorter than I don't need tend to do so
thank you for listening and bye for now